Everything we do takes time.
But how much time does it take?
Does it take seconds?
Does it take minutes?
Does it take hours?
Pablo wanted to make a sandwich.
He began at 12:00.
The big hand was pointing at the twelve.
The little hand was pointing at the twelve, too.
Pablo finished making the sandwich.
The big hand was pointing at the two.
The little hand was just past the twelve.
It took Pablo ten minutes to make the sandwich.
Amy wanted to paint a picture.
She began at 10 o'clock.
The big hand was pointing at the twelve.
The little hand was pointing at the ten.
Amy finished her painting.
The big hand was pointing at the 6.
The little hand was between the ten and the eleven.
It took Amy 30 minutes to paint the picture.
Jamie wanted to give her dog a bath.
She started at 2:30.
The big hand was pointing at the six.
The little hand was between the two and the three.
Jamie finished giving her dog a bath.
The big hand was pointing at the six.
The little hand was between the three and the four.
It took Jamie sixty minutes, or one hour, to give her dog a bath.
Dillon wanted to build a toy boat.
He started at 9:10.
The big hand was pointing at the two.
The little hand was just past the nine.
He finished the boat.
The big hand was pointing at the six.
The little hand was between the two and the three.
The big hand went around and around.
It went around five times.
It took Dillon five hours and twenty minutes to build the boat.
When we do things we love, we sometimes forget about time.